Uno del que todo el mundo estuviese hablando,
uno que los afectase directamente.
¿Harían todo lo que esté a su alcance para arreglar las cosas
antes de que empeoren?
No estén tan seguros.
Somos mucho más propensos de lo que nos gustaría admitir
a pasar por alto lo que está frente a nuestros ojos.
Y, de hecho,
a veces somos más propensos a alejarnos de los problemas
precisamente porque para nosotros representan una amenaza
en los negocios, la vida y el mundo.
Quiero darles un ejemplo de mi mundo: la política económica.
Cuando Alan Greenspan era presidente de la Reserva Federal,
su trabajo consistía en atender los problemas económicos de EE. UU.
y asegurarse de que no se saliesen de control.
Entonces, después del 2006,
cuando los precios inmobiliarios alcanzaron su pico,
fue cada vez mayor la cantidad de líderes e instituciones respetables
que hicieron a sonar las alarmas de alerta
sobre los préstamos de riesgo y el peligro de las burbujas del mercado.
Como saben, en el 2008 todo se vino abajo.
Los bancos colapsaron,
los mercados bursátiles del mundo perdieron casi la mitad de su valor,
y millones de personas perdieron sus hogares por la ejecución hipotecaria.
Y en el fondo de todo,
cerca de uno de cada diez estadounidenses se quedó sin trabajo.
Después de que las cosas se calmaron un poco,
Greenspan y muchos otros publicaron un balance que afirmaba lo siguiente:
"Nadie podría haber predicho esta crisis".
Lo llamaron un 'cisne negro'.
Algo que era inimaginable,
imprevisible y totalmente improbable.
Una verdadera sorpresa.
Excepto que no siempre fue una sorpresa.
Por ejemplo, mi departamento en Manhattan casi duplicó su valor
en menos de cuatro años.
Advertí lo que se avecinaba, y lo vendí.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Muchas personas también vieron las señales
y lo advirtieron públicamente
pero fueron ignorados.
No sabíamos exactamente cómo iba a ser la crisis,
no conocíamos los parámetros exactos,
pero todos podíamos prever
que lo que se venía era tan peligroso, visible y previsible
como un enorme rinoceronte gris que iba directamente hacia nosotros.
El concepto de cisne negro da la idea de que no tenemos control alguno
sobre nuestro futuro.
Y, desafortunadamente, cuanto menos control creemos tener,
es mucho más probable que minimicemos el problema
o lo ignoremos completamente.
Y esta peligrosa dinámica oculta otra cuestión:
muchos de los problemas a los que nos enfrentamos
son sumamente probables y obvios.
Son problemas que podemos ver, pero aun así elegimos no hacer nada.
A partir de esto, creé la metáfora del rinoceronte gris
para satisfacer lo que consideraba una necesidad urgente,
para ayudarnos a mirar con nuevos ojos,
y con el mismo fervor que la gente sintió por el cisne negro,
pero esta vez, hacia las cosas que eran sumamente obvias,
sumamente probables, pero aun así ignoradas.
Esos son los rinocerontes grises.
Una vez que empiezas a buscarlos
los ves todos los días en las noticias.
Y lo que veo en los titulares es otro enorme rinoceronte gris:
la alta probabilidad de una nueva crisis financiera.
Y me pregunto si hemos aprendido algo en estos últimos diez años.
Si escuchamos a Washington o Wall Street,
estamos casi perdonados por pensar que todo iría viento en popa.
Pero en China, donde viví mucho tiempo,
la conversación era totalmente distinta.
Desde el equipo de economistas hasta el mismo presidente Xi Jiping,
hablan específica y claramente de los riesgos financieros,
como son los rinocerontes grises,
y cómo pueden domarlos.
Para aclarar, China y EE. UU. tienen sistemas de gobierno muy diferentes,
y eso determina qué pueden hacer y qué no.
Y muchas de las principales causas de sus problemas económicos
son totalmente diferentes.
Pero no es ningún secreto que ambos países tienen problemas
con la deuda, la desigualdad y la productividad económica.
Entonces ¿por qué tendrían conversaciones tan diferentes?
Esta pregunta podría aplicarse no solo a los países,
sino a casi todas las personas.
A las empresas automotrices que priorizan la seguridad
y las que no se molestan en retirar sus autos defectuosos
hasta que la gente muere.
A los abuelos que, en el proceso de prepararse para lo inevitable
los que tienen escrito el panegírico,
el menú que se comerá en el funeral.
(Risas)
Mis abuelos lo hicieron.
Todo menos la fecha final grabada en la lápida.
Por otra parte, hay abuelos que no dejan sus asuntos en orden,
no se deshacen de los cachivaches que acumularon por décadas
y luego los hijos deben ocuparse.
Entonces ¿qué marca la diferencia entre un lado y el otro?
¿Por qué algunas personas ven las cosas y se ocupan,
mientras que otras apartan la vista?
El primer motivo tiene que ver con la cultura, la sociedad,
con la gente que nos rodea.
Si piensan que alguien cercano
los va a ayudar a levantarse cuando se caigan,
es más probable que el peligro les parezca menor.
Y eso nos permite arriesgarnos para lo bueno, no solo para lo malo.
Por ejemplo, arriesgarse a la crítica
cuando hablas del peligro del que nadie quiere que hables.
O aprovechar oportunidades que pueden asustar un poco,
que, a su manera, son rinocerontes grises.
Estados Unidos tiene una cultura muy individualista, la de hacerlo solos.
Y, paradójicamente,
esto hace que muchos estadounidenses sean menos abiertos al cambio
y a correr los riesgos buenos.
En cambio, en China,
la gente cree que el gobierno va a evitar que ocurran problemas,
lo cual podría no ser siempre así, pero la gente lo cree.
Creen que pueden contar con sus familias,
y eso los hace más propensos a correr ciertos riesgos,
como comprar inmuebles en Pekín,
o abrirse a un cambio de rumbo
y, en efecto, la velocidad de cambio en China es muy sorprendente.
En segundo lugar,
¿cuánto saben de una situación,
y cuánto están dispuestos a aprender?
¿Y están dispuestos a ver cosas incluso cuando no es lo que quieren?
Es muy poco probable
que prestemos atención a cosas que queremos ocultar,
que no nos gustan.
Prestamos atención a lo que queremos ver, lo que nos gusta,
lo que coincide con nuestra opinión.
Pero tenemos la oportunidad y la habilidad de corregir esos puntos ciegos.
Pasé mucho tiempo hablando con gente de todos los estratos sociales
sobre los rinocerontes grises de sus vidas y de sus actitudes.
Y bien podríamos pensar
que las personas con más miedo de correr riesgos,
las más sensibles a esos temores,
serían las menos abiertas al cambio.
Pero en realidad, ocurre lo contrario.
Descubrí que la gente
dispuesta a reconocer los problemas a su alrededor y a hacer planes
es la que puede tolerar más riesgos, riesgos buenos,
y lidiar con los riesgos malos.
Y es porque cuando buscamos información,
aumentamos nuestra capacidad de hacer algo con las cosas que nos dan miedo.
Lo cual me lleva a mi tercer punto.
¿Cuánto creen que pueden controlar los rinocerontes grises en sus vidas?
Unas de las razones por la que no actuamos
es porque muchas veces nos sentimos impotentes.
El cambio climático, por ejemplo, parece algo tan grande
que ninguno de nosotros podría marcar una diferencia.
Por eso, algunas personas van por la vida negándolo.
Otros culpan a todos, excepto a ellos mismos.
Como mi amigo que dice que no renunciará a su vehículo
hasta que dejen de construir plantas de carbón en China.
Pero tenemos la oportunidad de cambiar.
No hay dos personas iguales.
Cada uno de nosotros tiene la oportunidad de cambiar su actitud,
la nuestra y la de quienes nos rodean.
Hoy, quiero invitarlos a todos Uds.
a que me ayuden a iniciar una conversación abierta y sincera
con la gente que los rodea
sobre los rinocerontes grises en el mundo,
y evaluar con despiadada sinceridad si los estamos manejando bien.
Escucho demasiadas veces en EE. UU.:
"Claro que deberíamos tratar los problemas obvios
pero, si no los tienes enfrente, o eres tonto o ignorante".
Eso es lo que dicen, y estoy en total desacuerdo.
Si no vemos lo que tenemos enfrente,
no somos tontos ni ignorantes.
Somos humanos.
Y una vez que todos reconozcamos esa vulnerabilidad compartida,
tendremos el poder de abrir los ojos
para ver lo que está frente a nosotros
y actuar antes de que nos aplasten.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.